[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial duels au sommaire
aujourd'hui deux états historiquement
antagonistes la corée du nord et la
corée du sud
leurs relations se détériorent à une
vitesse alarmante obligeant à faire une
croix sur la récente détente et mettant
en danger la sécurité régionale
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre en voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur les leaders des deux
corées rival c'est le bide
âgé de 68 ans mon jean est né sur l'île
de coacher dans une famille de réfugiés
du nord
après ses études secondaires il entre en
1972 à l'université et yang i pour y
étudier le droit
plus tard il sera arrêté et exclu de
l'université pour avoir organisé une
manifestation contre le gouvernement
il parvient tout de même à finir ses
études en 1981 et entame une carrière
d'avocat près de trente ans son cadet
kim jong-un est né selon la version
officielle de sa biographie en 1982 à
pyongyang
fils du dirigeant nord coréen kim jong
il il passe son enfance dans la maison
familiale entourée de gardes du corps
cela ne l'empêché pas de partir de temps
en temps à l'étranger en usant d'une
fausse identité il fait tout de même ses
études secondaires en suisse de 93 à
2000 à son retour en corée du nord il
poursuit une formation d'officier
d'infanterie en vue de prendre
prochainement la tête du pays moujahid
lui ne songeait pas une carrière
politique
au début de sa carrière professionnelle
à leurs avocats
il se rapproche de son collègue roh
moo-hyun lui aussi avocat et activiste
coréen celui-ci s'engage plus tard dans
la politique et décide d'y à un relais
moon monde jeanine accepte de s'occuper
en 2002 de la campagne présidentielle de
son ami roh moo-hyun remporte les
élections est le nomme conseiller pour
les affaires civiles
jusqu'en 2006 puis chef du cabinet
présidentiel de 2007 à 2008
à cette époque kim jong hoon se prépare
activement à remplacer son père et
apprend à gérer le pays les choses
s'accélèrent à partir de 2008 quand kim
jong il est victime d'un avc
il désigne alors son fils en tant que
successeur en 2011 kim jong-il meure kim
jong hoon entre officiellement en
fonctions pour moudjahid le chemin vers
la présidence est plus compliqué un an
après la fin de son mandat roh moo-hyun
se suicident à la suite d'un scandale de
corruption mondial décide de grimper les
échelons du pouvoir fin 2011 et le
rejoins le parti démocrate unifiée
devient candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2012 mais perd face à
part gollier pourtant après un scandale
de corruption impliquant la présidente
et la destitution de cette dernière moon
fait une deuxième tentative et remporte
enfin le scrutin en 2017
une fois président il plaide notamment
pour une politique d'apaisement à
l'égard de la corée du nord kim jong
hoon quant à lui montre des signes
d'ouverture dès son arrivée au pouvoir
il est par exemple le premier dirigeant
nord-coréen a traversé la frontière
entre les deux corées a rencontré en
président américain en même temps qui
m'a prône le renforcement de l'arsenal
nucléaire du pays et procède
régulièrement à des essais de missiles
balistiques formellement les deux pays
sont toujours en état de guerre près de
soixante dix ans après la fin de la
guerre de corée l'accord de paix n'est
toujours pas conclue entre le nord et le
sud est aujourd'hui peu de progrès sont
réalisés dans cette direction au
contraire on constate un regain de
tension kim jong-un développe un arsenal
nucléaire et mènent régulièrement des
essais de missiles balistiques mondial
lui modernise ses forces armées et
achètent de plus en plus d'équipements
militaires la coopération de plus en
plus étroite entre les etats-unis et la
corée du sud jette de l'huile sur le feu
ap washington - jean reno aussi les
liens avec tokyo et se rapproche de
l'inde la corée du nord elle compte
principalement sur l'aide économique et
militaire dans son principal allié
pékin comment les relations
intercoréennes ont elles évolué sous les
dirigeants actuels de quoi s'accuse
pyongyang et séoul
enfin quel avenir se dessine pour les
deux corées pour répondre à ces
questions nous rejoignons patrick maurus
professeur émérite à l'inalco et
directeur de la revue temps ghosn
monsieur maurus bonjour bonjour de pas
mal de rumeurs anecdotes et mythes sur
kim gens
hoon circulent dans les médias qui est
il en fait est il plutôt le produit du
système comme si jean ping ou at il plus
d'indépendance dans ses actions au je
vais vous répondre qu'il est les deux à
la fois c'est à dire qu'il est il est le
système il est le système il leur
présente il est le troisième de la
famille qui est quand même un cas très
particulier dans l'histoire récente
mais quand on a dit ça on n'a pas
forcément résolue la question c'est à
dire qu'est ce que c'est que ce système
dont il est le la vitrine le chef le
représentant au dernier congrès pas
celui qui vient d'avoir lieu sud avant
le 7ème congrès le système a été
réorganisé des passions tripartite c'est
à dire le parti l'armée et le
gouvernement chose quand on parle plus
trop depuis d'ailleurs en tout cas il y
avait une sorte de réorganisation sous
un terme général qui sans doute nous
parlera plus il a nommé le parti le
parti du leader
le leader est en lui-même ce qui montre
quand même une place très particulière
mais ça ne règle pas non plus totalement
la question et je fais aussi brève que
possible
de quel parti s'agit-il de quel système
s'agit-il philippe ans le journaliste a
publié un livre avec un titre très
évocateur qui est l'état guérilla à
savoir que ce régime a été créé avec
l'aide de l'union soviétique à l'époque
a été créé sur la base des peu nombreux
partisans de la guérilla coréenne
pendant l'occupation japonaise en moins
de souris et depuis et même encore
maintenant d'une certaine façon ce
régime s'est toujours appuyé d'abord et
avant tout sur ce petit milieu de
d'anciens résistants et d'anciens
maquisards
parlons maintenant de moudjahidine
peut-on dire qu'il est vraiment partisan
de la réunification des deux corées qui
les artisans
de la paix comme on l'appelle parfois
dans les médias s'il ne l'est pas ce
serait dommage pour lui dans la mesure
où c'est ça sa marque de fabrique c'est
ça sa réputation et c'est aussi le la
raison pour laquelle il va rester
certainement dans dans l'histoire
contemporaine il a il a réorienté la
politique sud coréenne vers une
politique de la main tendue et de
l'apaisement
simplement il ya une opposition interne
il ya aussi une opposition ou une
attitude très changeantes de la part des
américains opposition interne vous
l'avez peut-être vu ce matin avec le
résultat des élections municipales en
corée du sud qui sont catastrophiques
que pour son régime au profit de ce
qu'on appelle gentiment la droite mais
qui en corée du sud et une extrême
extrême droite mais c'est un homme très
important et je ne pense pas du tout du
tout du tout que on en est terminée avec
ces propositions d'accord avec la corée
du nord
quelle que soit la grée si vite et mon
petit fond on peut dire agressivité des
états unis aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup monsieur moore us nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous vous retrouverons à la
fin de cette émission pour plus de
détails sur la question merci encore
autrefois unis 1 1 seul et à la corée du
nord et la corée du sud n'ont presque
rien en commun
aujourd'hui idéologie système politique
économique et social ces divergences
résulte largement de la séparation des
deux corées au moment de la guerre
froide
autrefois unis la corée vit la majeure
partie de son histoire coincé entre deux
puissant empire chinois et japonais
après la seconde guerre mondiale les
japonais qui occupaient la péninsule
jusqu'ici déposent les armes
la corée est administré par les deux
superpuissances urss au nord et les
états unis au sud
la frontière est délimité par le 38e
parallèle initialement aucun des deux
camps et encore moins les coréens
n'avait l'intention de laisser le pays
séparé en deux pourtant le début de la
guerre froide et les divisions qui
éclate entre l'urss et les états unis ne
leur ont pas permis de s'entendre sur
les conditions de l'unification de
l'état coréen dans chacune des parties
qu'il contrôle
moscou et washington encourage
l'organisation d'élections au sud celle
ardent anticommuniste sigman riz qui
était lui en 1948 la république de corée
et fonder son leader kim il song prend
la tête du pays
proclamant la république populaire
démocratique de corée les deux pays
disputent la totalité du territoire
coréen toujours en 1948 l'urss retire
ses troupes du nord et l'année suivante
il états unis font de même
la situation sécuritaire se dégrade
pourtant les affrontements frontaliers
deviennent de plus en plus récurrents
entre les deux pays en 1950 une
incursion supposé de l'armée sud
coréenne fait perdre patience à
pyongyang kim il song ordonne une
offensive contre le sud
c'est la guerre et nord-coréen
envahissent quasiment tout le sud est
sont part de séoul
les états unis viennent en aide à la
corée du sud et mènent une contre
offensive au nord pyongyang lui s'assure
du soutien de pékin
la guerre dure trois ans et finit par la
signature d'une trêve qui instaure une
zone démilitarisée au 38e parallèle
entre les deux corées elle s'accuse de
provocation et joue des muscles l'une
devant l'autre
les relations entre les deux corées se
complexifie de plus en plus le 25 mars
2021 et en gang procède au lancement de
deux missiles balistiques de courte
portée en mer du japon selon l'agencé de
presse officielle nord-coréenne il
s'agit d'une arme nouvellement
développés qui peut transporter une
ogive nucléaire pesant jusqu'à deux
tonnes et demie et manoeuvré pendant le
vol
ces essais provoque une vive réaction de
la communauté internationale le
et initie une enquête sur ce lancement
les etats-unis et leurs alliés condamne
ces tests le président sud coréen lui se
joint à ces déclarations et exprime sa
préoccupation
ce qui lui vaut les foudres de la soeur
de kim jong-un
il n'y aura aucune raison d'être
offensées si nous lui donnons les loges
qu'il est un perroquet américain pour
pyongyang les test nord-coréen ne sont
que la réponse à la provocation de séoul
et de washington leur exercice militaire
conjoint organisé en mars
il ne s'agit pourtant pas de manoeuvre
sur le terrain mais d'une simulation sur
ordinateur
les exercices de défense et de contre
attaque dure neuf jours les militaires
qui est participent des deux côtés ne
sont pas nombreux en raison de la
pandémie de kobe de 19
dès son arrivée au pouvoir moudjahid
renforce progressivement l'amitié
américano sud coréennes en matière de la
défense cependant la modernisation de
l'armée nationale est sa priorité
absolue ils augmentent donc
drastiquement le budget militaire et
achètent de plus en plus d'équipements
de guerre
en plus il lance des tests de missiles
balistiques et la construction du
premier porte avions sud coréens en 2020
séoul l'an son premier satellite de
communications militaires devenant le
dixième pays au monde à posséder un
satellite de communication à des fins
militaires uniquement c ur cherche donc
à développer ses capacités militaires
dans l'optique d'un transfert du
contrôle en temps de guerre de ses
forces armées actuellement détenus par
les états unis exercices militaires
lancement de missiles modernisation
accélérée de l'armée tout cela
représente un contraste sensible par
rapport à un certain apaisement démarré
il y à peu dans les relations
bilatérales
trois rencontres au plus haut niveau en
une seule année le record est battu en
2018 lorsque kim jong-un et moudjahidine
s'accordent pour enterrer la hache de
guerre le désarmement mutuelle
progressif l'arrêt de toute action
hostile la dénucléarisation de la corée
du nord lé premier pas concret sont fait
la même année kim jong-un démantèle
alors le site nucléaire de pont guéri
mots
et lui arrête la diffusion de musique
est de messages de propagande à la
frontière nord mais la détente aura été
de courte durée
les deux côtés se pointent du doigt
s'accusant mutuellement de violation des
accords et de provocation la goutte qui
a fait déborder le vase et la reprise de
la propagande par les transfuges
nord-coréens qui depuis le sud envoie au
nord des tracts accrochés à des ballons
ou insérés dans des bouteilles en juin
2020 pyongyang fait sauter le bureau de
liaison avec le sud située près de la
frontière et annonce l'envoi de 12
millions de tracts en corée du sud sur
qui peut compter la corée du nord à
l'international comment la corée du sud
cherche-t-elle à renforcer l' isolement
diplomatique de son voisin du nord
quel avenir se dessine pour les
relations bilatérales
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
sous pression de tous les côtés la corée
du nord peut-elle compter sur l'appui de
ses alliés et qui sont ils avant d'aller
plus loin
faisons le récap antagonistes historique
les deux corées le sont aussi sur le
plan diplomatique un qu'elle maintienne
les relations officielles avec la
majeure partie de la communauté
internationale
elle prône l' amitié avec divers quand
la corée du nord qu opère principalement
avec la chine son partenaire numéro un
et la russie la corée du sud un vaste
réseau de partenaires dans la région
mais entretient des relations
particulièrement étroites avec les états
unis et ses alliés
les deux corées font partie de
nombreuses organisations internationales
telles que l'onu l'unesco et l' oms
séoul est en outre membres de l'apec et
du g20 la corée du nord quant à elle
fait face à un isolement diplomatique
qui prend de l'ampleur depuis 2006 cette
année là le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
imposé des sanctions sur la corée du
nord en raison de ses essais nucléaires
malgré la nouvelle vague de tensions
autour des tests de missiles le
principal allié nord coréen
reste à ses côtés la chine vient de le
confirmer son engagement auprès du petit
frère coréen reste inébranlable à la
plus grande satisfaction de kim jong-un
le camarade kim jong-un a souligné la
nécessité de consolider la cohésion et
la collaboration entre les deux partis
les deux pays
la rdpc et la rpc dans la résistance aux
défis multilatéraux et aux obstacles de
lapins des forces ennemies en effet les
liens avec pékin sont une bouée de
sauvetage pour pyongyang
la chine est d'abord le principal allié
militaire de kim jong-un selon le traité
de défense mutuelle
elle est obligée d'intervenir en cas
d'agression contre pyongyang
et surtout la chine est le plus grand
partenaire commercial de la corée du
nord
elles représentent 90% de tous ces
échanges internationaux puis an giang
fourni à pékin de l'électricité du
charbon et de l'acier et achètent de la
nourriture des biens de consommation et
des matériaux de base
malgré les sanctions de l'onu ces
échanges se poursuivent en partie de
manière clandestine selon plusieurs
think tanks
maintenue à flots grâce aux échanges
commerciaux avec pékin pyongyang doit
ses succès mais les terres à une autre
alliance opaque
la corée du nord développerai ces
missiles balistiques en collaboration
avec l'iran c'est ce qu'affirme le
rapport confidentiel de l'onu révélé par
la lfp en février dernier selon ce texte
la dernière instance de cette
coopération date de 2020
pyongyang et téhéran aurait échangé des
composants essentiels et des
technologies sur les missiles de longue
portée
l'iran dément toutes ces informations
face à séoul pyongyang a aussi besoin
d'alliés ouvert en janvier kim jong-un
annonce un nouveau cap
développer et étendre les relations
étrangères et pas avec n'importe qui en
mars ils adressent de rats un message
aux pies socialiste vietnam laos et cuba
il a encore une fois clarifier la
volonté du parti démocrate de corps et
de développer des liens d'unité de
coopération stratégique et amicales avec
cuba sur le chemin du combat pour la
victoire de la cause socialiste et
d'engager lutte commune dynamique contre
l'impérialisme une stratégie qui
ressemble comme deux gouttes d'eau à
celle de son adversaire du sud
moujahid table aussi sur les alliés
traditionnels et oeuvre pour consolider
ces liens
surtout avec sont plus proches
partenaires les états unis après le
mandat tumultueux de trump moudjahid ne
cache pas son enthousiasme à l'arrivée
de joe biden à la présidence
nous saluons le retour de l'amérique le
retour de la diplomatie et la relance
des alliances avec l'arrivée de
l'administration byden en effet pour
moudjahid le nouveau pouvoir à
washington signifie aussi de nouvelles
ouvertures diplomatiques
tout d'abord avec le japon car depuis
2018 l'animosité entre tokyo et séoul
est palpable guerre commerciale qui en
pire crise diplomatique à répétition en
cause des griefs de l'histoire commune
de la seconde guerre mondiale pourtant
la corée du sud profite de l'arrivée de
joe biden au pouvoir pour surmonter les
tensions
seoul accepte volontiers la médiation
américaine et en moins de deux mois
la querelle nippo coréenne cède la place
à la détente
une évolution qui en entraîne d'autres
après tokyo séoul approfondi ses liens
militaires avec un autre ami des
etats-unis l'inde
ensuite après plusieurs mois de refus
c'est où le s'ouvre à l'idée de
rejoindre l'alliance quad
ce bloc militaire comprend les états
unis le japon l'australie et l'inde
il est formé en 2017 sous donald trump
dans le but de contrer l'influencé de
pékin vers 2021 le poids de dépasse
l'agenda anti chinois s attaquent aux
défis plus globaux dans son viseur le
climat les vaccins l'économie mais aussi
la corée du nord appelée à le rejoindre
séoul se méfie tout de même de sa
position hostile envers pyongyang et
pékin washington et son meilleur allié
mais pékin reste son premier partenaire
commercial
un équilibre en soit difficile mais mon
jean est un négociateur expérimenté et
il va même jusqu'à ajouter un troisième
élément dans cette équation la russie
fin mars le président accueille une
délégation de diplomates russes assez
aux visites en plein pic des test
nord-coréen
seoul eux comptent sur moscou pour
apaiser les tensions
en effet la russie a un rôle historique
dans cette dispute ses propres intérêts
commerciaux et stratégiques est en
minimes en plus moscou à la confiance
des deux corées
du coup le 29 mars séoul demande à la
russie de parrainer le règlement de la
nouvelle crise intercoréenne
la médiation russe pourrait-elle changer
la donne entre le nord et le sud
pourquoi aucun des deux états ne peuvent
vraiment se permettre une escalade
avant d'aller plus loin rappel des faits
sur les deux corées ayant vécu ensemble
pendant des siècles les deux corées ont
aujourd'hui très peu de choses en commun
alors qu'au nord la totalité du pouvoir
est entre les mains du seul parti de kim
jong-un le sud possède depuis plusieurs
décennies un système démocratique avec
le président comme chef d'état du point
de vue commercial la corée du nord à une
économie planifiée où l'état joue un
rôle crucial
les tentatives de kim jong-un de la
réforme et ne donne qu'un effet limité
le plus grand partenaire commercial est
le principal donateur de la corée du
nord et la chine
à son tour la corée du sud à une
économie de marché et se situe parmi les
20 pays les plus riches au monde
l'un des plus grand hub technologique du
monde elle produit principalement de
l'équipement électronique puces
électroniques ordinateurs télé portable
sa population présente également une
différence notable plus de 50 millions
d'habitants en corée du sud contre
environ 25 millions au nord déjà isolé à
l'international la corée du nord l'a été
encore plus pendant la pandémie pour se
protéger du virus en 2020 elle coupe
littéralement tous ses contacts avec le
monde extérieur transports commerces
courriel frontières tout ça sur fond de
confinement strict dans le pays selon le
ms depuis le début de la pandémie la
corée du nord n'a signalé aucun cas de
kovy de 19 sur son sol néanmoins cela un
prix avant le vide l'économie
nord-coréen souffrait déjà des sanctions
et 2020 lui porte un coup fatal
confinement catastrophes naturelles gel
d'importation ou ça paralyse l'industrie
et même au déficit de médicaments et de
nourriture
presque toutes les ambassades sont
fermés les étrangers totalement
délaissées
evad de la corée du nord parfois à pied
de l'autre côté de la frontière la
pandémie a aussi laissé des traces en
2020 l'économie sud-coréenne se
contracte pour la première fois en 22
ans le pib perd 1%
c'est le pire résultat depuis la crise
économique de 1998 de même pour le
chômage au plus haut niveau depuis deux
décennies
5 4% en janvier dernier une crise qui
survient sur fond de grave déclin
démographique et de vieillissement
rapide de la population
en 2020 le taux de natalité atteint 0,84
le pire sur la planète
malgré les difficultés un interne séoul
décide de donner un exemple à
l'international la corée du sud
envoie de l'aide humanitaire vers le
nord et plaide en faveur de la levée de
quelques sanctions qui pèsent sur
pyongyang
nous observons la corée du nord de très
près et craignons une crise humanitaire
pour la corée la corée du nord n'est pas
un simple voisins nous partageons notre
héritage notre terre la terre et l'eau
les pays aux ressources abondantes doit
soutenir ceux qui n'en n'ont pas sauf
que pyongyang refuse d'ouvrir ses
frontières même pour recevoir de l'aide
humanitaire
et pourtant un dégel se profile quand
même entre le nord et le sud
le 1er avril 2021 les deux corées ont
postulé ensemble auprès du cio pour
accueillir conjointement les jeux
olympiques de 2000 32 une promesse enfin
réaliser de moudjahidine et kim jong-un
convenu lors de leur dernier sommet en
septembre 2018
l'année où les jeux olympiques avaient
aussi rapproché les deux corées à
pyeongchang en 2018
les sportives des deux corées défiler
ensemble sous un drapeau unifiée dans
les tribunes en hôte d'honneur la
responsable nord coréenne kim yu zhang
soeur de kim jong-un pour développer ce
succès et reprendre les pourparlers
séoul miser sur les jo de tokyo
cependant au mois d'avril et pyongyang
annonce son refus d'y participer à cause
de la pandémie au grand dam de son
voisin
comme il reste un certain temps avant
l'ouverture des jo qui sont une fête
internationale pour la paix nous
espérons que la corée du nord y
participera le coup de froid revient dès
2019 mais les deux dirigeants
maintiennent des relations à peu près
correct pour mon jean
la réunification coréenne reste une
priorité tant politiques que familial
fils de réfugiés du nord il rêve
d'emmener sa mère dans sa ville natale
ce sentiment est largement partagé des
deux côtés de la frontière en corée du
sud la réunification est soutenu par la
plupart de la population en 2020 70 2%
et était favorable à en 2018 ce chiffre
s'élevait même à 1 77% et en corée du
nord l'enthousiasmé est encore plus
grand le taux d'approbation de la
réunification atteint 94 4 % en 2017
pour y voir plus clair nous rejoignons
de nouveau patrick maurus professeur
émérite à l'inalco directeur de la revue
tango monsieur maurus la confrontation
actuelle entre les etats-unis et la
chine va-t-elle selon-vous polariser la
région et par conséquent coupera tel
définitivement les chances de pyongyang
de rétablir les relations avec
l'occident
on a envie de voir les choses comme ça
tellement les déclarations et les prises
de position des uns et des autres sont
marqués saignante noir ou blanc à tout
moment heureusement pour une fois la
situation est beaucoup plus compliquée
si vous vous trimballer un petit peu je
suis sûr que c'est votre cas d'un pays à
l'autre en extrême orient
vous ne pouvez pas ne pas être frappé
par le fait que les opinions publiques
et j'aimais le mot ou plurielle y
compris dans un seul pays
les opinions publiques sont extrêmement
ambivalente autant les amis américains
sont extrêmement intéressant quand on
voit que les chinois sont un petit peu
envahissant où étaient des guillemets à
tout ça autant de l'autre côté vous avez
le même mouvement
c'est à dire
l'impression que la chine est
définitivement un acteur important de la
région qu'il faut discuter et temporiser
avec elle et que les américains ne sont
pas forcément légitime dans cette région
donc ce mouvement de balancier entre les
deux grandes puissances fait que
beaucoup de petits pays petit pays vous
avez compris ce que je voulais dire et
c'est de se glisser un petit peu entre
les deux j'espère pour eux que le
proverbe coréen quand les baleines se
bat ce sont les crevettes qui se font
écraser ne sera pas valable
et donc ce proverbe qu'en est-il dans la
réunification des deux corées
pensez vous qu'un jour elles seront
réunifiées la question est très très
intéressante ou bon aujourd'hui n'ont
rien aujourd'hui c'est bloqué c'est
absolument blue king brown
il y aura pas d'avancée visible même si
bien entendu il y à quantité de
négociations qui se passe en dehors de
notre regard maintenant cette problème
de réunification
le mot est beau ou une réunification
l'indépendance démocratie liberté dont
on est tous pour seulement techniquement
qu'est ce que cela veut dire
la corée est divisée depuis 75 ans c'est
à dire depuis plus longtemps que
l'existence de l'ex union soviétique
pour vous donner une mesure que vous
comprenez cette réunification consiste à
réunifier quelque chose qui étaient
unifiés préalablement c'est à dire un
état colonial pas une corée indépendante
toute l'histoire de la corée y est une
histoire de division et de réunification
et ce depuis des centaines d'années
donc ce slogan aujourd'hui réunification
réunification il est plus un quant à
thouars que programmatique me
semble-t-il
ce qui n'empêche pas les coréens de
joueurs se réunifier au sud on en parle
très dont en corée du nord quel que soit
le nord coréen que je rends compte
enfants des écoles ou paysans on me pose
cette question
merci beaucoup monsieur maurus patrick
maurus professeur émérite à l'inalco et
directeur de la revue ton goût n'était
aujourd'hui avec nous pour son éclairage
merci encore
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]